صحيح أن التداعيات مستمرة
لرؤساء بعض أفضل
الجامعات في الولايات المتحدة بعد أن قام
المشرعون باستجوابهم حول
حوادث مختلفة معاداة السامية في
حرمهم الجامعي، وقد شهد رؤساء ولاية بنسلفانيا أه معهد
ماساتشوستس للتكنولوجيا وجامعة هارفارد جميعًا عند
الضغط على معاداة السامية  السلوك في
جامعة هارفارد رفض رئيسها إدانته
بعد عدة فرص للقيام
بذلك في جامعة هارفارد هل الدعوة إلى
الإبادة الجماعية لليهود تنتهك قواعد هارفارد
الخاصة بالبلطجة والتحرش نعم أو لا
يمكن أن يعتمد ذلك على السياق
ما هو السياق المستهدف كفرد
مستهدف كفرد  تجاه فرد
يستهدف الطلاب اليهود
أفرادًا يهودًا، هل تفهم أن
شهادتك تجردهم من إنسانيتهم، هل
تفهم أن التجريد من الإنسانية هو جزء
من معاداة
السامية، سأسألك مرة أخرى هل
الدعوة إلى الإبادة الجماعية
لليهود تنتهك قواعد التنمر في جامعة هارفارد؟
التحرش نعم أو
لا خطاب معاد للسامية متى يكون
خطابًا معاديًا للسامية
خطابًا معاديًا للسامية عندما يعبر إلى سلوك يرقى
إلى مستوى التنمر والتحرش والترهيب
وهو سلوك قابل للتنفيذ
ونحن نتخذ إجراءً، لذا فإن الجواب هو
نعم الدعوة إلى الإبادة الجماعية
اليهود ينتهكون قواعد السلوك بجامعة هارفارد
[موسيقى]
صحيح مرة أخرى يعتمد ذلك على السياق